nous on mettra toutes nos forces dans la
bataille pour offrir à françois fillon
si les français lui font l'honneur de
les lire le 7 mai 2010 est une large
majorité à l'assemblée une majorité
solide qui lui permettra de mettre en
oeuvre son programme de redressement
enfin à l'occasion de ce conseil
national je voudrais souhaiter bon
courage à tous les candidats investis et
en particulier aux jeunes qui se lancent
pour la première fois dans cette
aventure
mon combat sera de ressouder notre
territoire pour qu'il redevienne hommes
et indivisible et pour que chacun y
trouve sa place
je suis heureuse aujourd'hui de nous
voir tous réunis lors de ce conseil
national autour de notre candidat
françois fillon et je suis convaincu
avec françois fillon que nous arriverons
à faire revivre notre bien commun de la
nation
ça sera avec honneur plaisir
enthousiasme et passion que je défendrai
à l'assemblée nationale la politique de
françois fillon est aujourd'hui pour ce
premier conseil national derrière notre
candidat je pourrais dire aux côtés de
notre candidat l'occasion de lancer un
grand appel à tous les français à
participer au débat et à écouter nos
propositions ce conseil national on vous
l'a tous dits extrêmement important car
après une primaire qui a été très belle
une primaire pleine de succès nous
devons tous être unis un mot pour ce
conseil national union union avec
françois fillon
union contre les attaques tous unis nous
allons gagner la présidentielle et nous
lui donnons une majorité très forte à
l'assemblée nationale alors on y va on y
va tous pour colak la france gagne vive
la république vive françois fillon et
vive les l air
[Musique]